we passed the American Rescue plan
now
everybody knows it but we did so much no
one knows the effects of it yet we're
just just they're just coming into play
what's up everybody it is November 30th
2022. I'm Dave Rubin this is the Reuben
report we are live streaming on Rumble
YouTube and Blaze TV if you haven't
subscribed over at rumble.com Reuben
report please do it if you want to play
along during the show don't forget you
can chat with us Stephanie's sitting
right over there she has some sort of
computer in front of her you can send
her messages while I'm doing this they
might even get to me during the show go
to reubenreport.locals.com we also have
an IOS app and uh Android app and all
that good stuff and I am going out on a
limb uh at the top of the show today to
tell you we got a 9-5 to a 9-7 show out
of ten okay I feel good today I feel
like this show kind of wrote itself
there's a lot going on in the world and
we pieced it together like a perfect
Lego set I think you're gonna dig it uh
what we're going to be talking about is
sort of more of an extension of what
I've been sort of Shifting towards a
little bit lately which is more of the
culture War stuff than the racehorse
politics stuff right you got to do the
resource politics stuff when elections
are coming but in between elections it
really is about the culture and if you
can kind of win culture then people vote
in certain ways that's why that famous
quote from Andrew Breitbart that
politics is Downstream from culture uh
really sort of took root so we're going
to talk about Elon and what's going on
with Twitter of course we're going to
talk about China and apple we're going
to talk about Alyssa Milano who doesn't
like that Elon fellow we're going to
talk about Justin Trudeau we're going to
talk about Joe Biden and a whole bunch
more so strap yourself in because it's
going to be a good one before we get to
it real quick let me talk to you guys
about Cozy Earth are you looking to
score a few extra points by giving the
perfect gift this holiday season I've
got two great ideas certain to have
family and friends bragging about how
thoughtful you are and both are from
Cozier the brand with thousands of five
star reviews including mine first cozy
Earth luxury bedding I own a set of
these sheets I seriously love them and
you can't believe how soft they are
they're not only super soft but they're
made from the finest premium viscous
from highly sustainable bamboo that
makes them naturally temperature
regulating so you'll sleep comfortably
year round I sure do and second anything
from their luxurious loungewear
collection including soft and stylish
bamboo pajamas joggers tees and more
I've got the pajama pants which I love
even here in Florida where it is a
little warm in case you haven't heard
while you're there check out their
premium plush and Waffle bath towels
they you'll love those too and every
cozy Earth bedding item comes in a very
cool reusable Canvas Bag save 40 percent
now on cozy earth hurry holiday offer
and soon go to cozyearth.com Dave and
save 40 That's cozyearth.com Dave
and now back to me okay culture wars
here we go so Alyssa Milano
if you're a child of a certain age
or you're an adult of a certain age but
you were a child at one point uh let's
say in the 80s you know Alyssa Milano
she was in who's the boss does who's the
boss mean anything to the three of you
in this room right now means absolutely
nothing to you Tony Danza
nothing you don't care Judith Light
the little gay kid you don't care about
that at all you just don't care
anyway it was a show on ABC in the 80s
she was on it she was kind of a star
then she was in Charmed which I think
was syndicated around the WB Channel
anyway now she's just become sort of a
hysterical woke leftist on Twitter all
day you know calling everyone racist but
she's like in the culture War she's just
one of these people that's in the
culture war and she went on yes you
guessed it the view yesterday and she is
not happy with Elon Musk because he's
letting everyone speak and there's
nothing that awoks or hates more than
that you know your name popped up over
the weekend when you tweeted that you
you returned your Tesla so um you used
to be a supporter of Elon musk's Vision
what happened what changed your mind
well I mean for me speaking of me too
when he was accused of sexual misconduct
and paid out 250 000 to this to this
person I decided like I can't live in
that hypocrisy of driving that car when
you know yeah uh that happened
they're okay
there's more don't worry uh first off in
the past she had tweeted several times
how much she uh liked and respected Elon
Musk and that he was one of the people
that she would love to have dinner with
and meet and all that stuff now I don't
know anything that is not public
knowledge about the Elon Musk metoo
situation and the money that he paid but
you know when you're when you're a high
Target like Elon Musk when you're
someone worth a gajillion dollars and
you're a public person there's all sorts
of people that come after you that come
with lawsuits that say you did this that
the other thing so he did settle for 250
Grand several people have pointed out or
200 Grand whatever it is several people
have pointed out you know that's really
next to nothing so it was more just like
can this headache go away whether it's
real or not but that's a sidebar what
this really about what this really is
about of course and why she was on The
View talking about Tesla and everything
else is because uh Elon Musk has bought
Twitter and he's allowing more people to
speak freely as I address the yesterday
there is no evidence and I would love if
someone out there is watching and can
find me a dossier or anything else is
there any evidence I think not that
there is suddenly more hate on Twitter
what she might be responding to and what
the media seems to be upset about is
that more right-leaning people let's say
more conservative leaning people are now
being seen on Twitter they're not being
Shadow banned as much they're not being
banned as much some of them that have
previously been booted off the platform
like Jordan Peterson and James Lindsay
are back but there's no evidence that
there is suddenly more hate on Twitter
and as I often say if you don't like the
hate that you're getting online and gosh
darn it people say mean things about me
uh you can mute them you can block them
you cannot open the app you could throw
your phone into a river you have options
anyway uh she gave back her Tesla
because she doesn't like Elon Musk the
Tesla is the coolest car and uh she just
doesn't want it because she believes in
what she believes but she kind of got
owned about it on the Twitter uh check
this out so she wrote I gave back my
Tesla I bought the Volkswagen electric
vehicle I love it I'm not sure how
advertisers can buy space on Twitter
publicly traded companies products being
pushed in alignment with hate and white
supremacy doesn't seem to be a winning
business model now just to address the
end of that there's just no evidence
that that's happening uh the Hodge twins
who as you can see there they happen to
be black I don't really care but it's
just sort of an interesting piece of the
puzzle said Volkswagen was literally
founded by the Nazis and Hitler
and this is what we call getting ratioed
getting ratio it is when you and the
response get more likes and retweets
than the original comment itself and
Elon Musk put a little smiley face and
the uh the 100 sign next to that I mean
it's all when you talk about virtue
signaling what is virtue signaling
virtue signaling is not actually having
virtue virtue signaling is signaling
that you have virtue her returning the
Tesla to get her ev even it had had it
not been founded by Hitler and the Nazis
it's just meaningless dribble and again
all elon's doing is defending the right
of people to speak but you know it and
what this really is all about is there's
a certain set of people that exist in
the world and and maybe all of us have a
dash of this that are deeply affected
when we read mean things or we see mean
things or when people say things about
us but that says more about us as
individual people than it does about I
would say the platform that it's being
set on right it's it's up to you whether
you take offense it's up to you whether
someone an anonymous frog person online
can write you're a bad dude and then
next thing you know you're about to jump
off the roof of the building uh Alyssa
Milano though she's a Hollywood actress
they're not noted for you know strong
sort of moral or psychological
conviction she had to go to therapy
because of Twitter right but do yourself
I know it is about self-care yeah it is
for one thing you've never ever read the
comments I always read the comments who
doesn't read the comments the comments
everybody says you go down the line yeah
you can never I know Whoopi and joy
taught us that don't read the comments
when we each joined the show do you turn
the comments off no I just don't read
them I'm not interested unless it's
somebody that I respect yeah well I have
another question I left she left yeah
I can't take it anymore I respect that
listen I've spent many many many days
with my therapist talking about about
what Anonymous person said to you yeah
right yeah people know you somebody who
doesn't know you hasn't yet you doesn't
know your family doesn't know you
doesn't know anything about you yeah but
we let them all right the given the
devil is due portion of this yes there
are mean Anonymous people there out
there and I can be completely dismissive
of it but yes sometimes they can say
something that really upsets you I find
when people are just like ah you're a
mean words like I don't care about that
I don't like when they selectively edit
what I say that's something that bothers
me I mean by me saying it just now I
probably instigated even more of it but
it's just it's just the nature of all of
this and before social media people used
to say mean things about people people
when I was a kid people used to write
mean things about people in the bathroom
stall that's you know that's what they
used to do you guys don't even know
about that young kids in here or you go
to clean bathrooms you don't know what
it was you I grew up it was New York
that's what people do mean things
um
people do say mean things I think
there's sort of a funny part of this how
joy and Whoopi are like no we never look
at the comments Joy only wants to hear
from people she respects I don't know
how you'd be able to do that on Twitter
only get responses from people you
respect uh you know my personal policy
on this is this is why I started locals
locals the locals guys watching right
now and that are in the chat I read the
comments every day I respond to as many
as I can every day uh I have because I
wanted to build a community the Twitter
is a town square and if you were walking
into the Town Square picture old school
we're back in the day let's go back a
hundred years right little towns All
Over America that are starting and then
in the Town Square that's where people
would congregate that's where you know
the the main stores were that's where
everybody would go for Commerce for to
eat to get food Etc and then they'd
start talking and exchanging ideas and
there might have even been a guy on a
soapbox there and he'd be complaining
about this or that but you did not have
to talk to everybody you did not have to
turn to everybody who commented on
something and if there was a crazy
person over there you might walk the
other way so I what I did with locals
was built something that was my own
personal community and it's a beautiful
thing Twitter I scan through the
comments but I'm not looking to just
fight with people all day or anything
else it's like lady grow up grow up
but again what this all is about it's
not about people being mean or anything
else it's that the left is losing the
narrative right
they're starting to lose the culture war
in a way because a guy like Elon Musk is
coming in he's cool he's got money he's
fighting for the right things and that's
upsetting to the powers that be and
Alyssa Milano is very upset that he's a
billionaire using his money to do what
he wants to do but also I'm kind of like
like I'm so annoyed with all of these
these billionaires with like the
exception of a few but especially Elon
Musk like
you buy Twitter to destroy it yeah for
40 billion dollars right 40 billion
dollars Elon Musk imagine if he donated
that money to UNICEF I know yeah he
would change the world there would be
there would be no hunger he would he
would he could go in his pocket and
donate that money he could go in his
pocket and it wouldn't cost 40 billion
these guys I mean
by the way they're so self-righteous so
self-righteous she doesn't like
billionaires except the billionaires
that she likes because they do the stuff
that she wants it's odds she has a
couple billionaires she likes they
haven't solved world hunger but I guess
Elon the guy that she basically thinks
is a Nazi she he should do what she
wants or I donate it to UNICEF that's
where she does some volunteer work I
suppose although I'm guessing she's
probably paid for it but uh putting all
of that aside he didn't buy it to
destroy it Twitter's numbers have been
bigger than ever this week he bought it
to save it but do you know what he
really bought it for he bought it so
that he could get around the basic
Gatekeepers the basic Gatekeepers that
have existed that have screwed up so
much when you wonder why so many people
are walking around with mental disorders
and so many people were so screwed up
because of covid and so many people had
trumped Arrangement syndrome it's
because the reality that we live in in a
day-to-day basis was not matching up on
the online reality because it was being
manipulated by walksters and social
justice Warriors that's why he went in
there in there and fired all these
people because we were Banning people
for saying basic truths like girls have
vaginas and boys have penises you used
to be able to say that sort of thing
if I have to say that one more time it
really is anyway The View program
continued all right this is the last one
I promise you and it's not a listen
Milano they brought on Samuel L Jackson
uh to talk about Twitter and Nazis
because clearly that's what he's an
expert in so yeah here you go so
assessment onto Club politician
you know in your day which I enjoy
um
that Elon Musk has taken over Twitter
I'm a little frightened to First Twitter
frankly what about you I just quit it
you know
there's so many more important things
that we have to deal with like we're
busy trying to get Raphael Walker
as opposed to an idiot who probably
doesn't even have a Twitter account that
can't use Twitter yeah but he's got a
big that's a big audience these Nazis
can come in on those on those social
media Elon Musk you know he's true I
have no idea what he is I don't even
know if he's a real he didn't invent
Tesla he's a businessman you're right
yeah
I honestly I'm sorry guys we'll have an
internal discussion about how many view
Clips but there is something so insane
about what's going on on that show every
day and that people are watching it
uh Joy thinks that the Nazis are back
guys just to be clear they're always
racists and there's always mean people
and some people don't like people
because of their skin color or because
of their religion and all sorts of bad
reasons the Nazis are not back and
they're not suddenly flocking to Twitter
and also a portion of what they they are
calling Nazis are literally like 16 year
old boys who are sitting in their room
putting a frog emoji on an account and
then writing mean things to them because
they just want to get a reaction out of
them that's how they're getting their
rocks off that's just how it is that's
internet culture but now he's not gonna
he's got more important things to do
than tweet because what does Samuel L
Jackson have to do what does he have to
do he has to get freaking Raphael
Warnock re-elected I mean Warnock is a
racist he is an absolute racist senator
from Georgia he's obviously got the
challenge coming in on this uh this
follow-up election from Herschel Walker
um also Joy like he didn't even invent
Tesla I couldn't hold a candle to him I
don't worship the guy but he's trying to
do something good
not only on this Earth but to get us to
other planets and look what you crazy
harpies do all day
you ah anywho Uh Kevin McCarthy who
likely will be the speaker of the house
they still have to work out some of the
voting now that the Republicans got
control of the house uh he was asked
about what's going on here because we
played you this video yesterday watching
the entire machine crash down on Elon
Musk just because he bought Twitter and
he's letting people speak so you saw the
video yesterday our black lesbian press
secretary Corinne Jean-Pierre saying the
government is monitoring Twitter
carefully and Joe Biden said he might
look into Elon musk's companies right he
doesn't know that he's done anything but
we're the government and we can look
into it so Kevin McCarthy was asked
about this and gosh darn it the
Republicans are getting some balls
listen to this being an eye on Twitter
under Elon Musk owners
that is offensive to me government's
going to go after someone that wants to
have free speech
what do they have to look at Twitter
about
do they want to go more after American
public about whether they can have an
opinion on something
I think the American public have spoken
on this I think our first amendment
stands up and I I think they should stop
picking on Elon Musk you know Elon Musk
has succeeded in many places I'd bet on
him more than government going after you
and I one thing I would say when we talk
about accountability will no longer let
government go after people simply
because of their political views hmm
that's right Kevin McCarthy look I know
a certain set of the right does not like
him they consider him to be too moderate
or something like that or a rhino or
whatever I've interviewed the guy I
think he's I think he's a decent man and
I think there's an opportunity for
Republicans what do I always say you
can't be a Democrat you don't have to be
you don't have to be a republican but
you can't be a Democrat right
there's a chance because the Republicans
will always fail you they always will
fail you but there is a chance they
could get a little Mojo right now
because things do feel like they're
shifting a little bit and with this
Twitter thing it's like there is a
chance to go around mainstream media
there's a chance to go around the sort
of pre-ordained narrative and get some
truth out there so good for Kevin
McCarthy for fighting this thing
properly good for him for saying that
the government is not going to use its
power to infringe on people's free
speech and come after people if the
Republicans can do nothing else let's
say for these next two years it's like
if they can Reign that back a little bit
make the administration a little more
fearful when Karin Jean-Pierre and Joe
Biden sit down and they're like who can
we flag on Facebook today uh that would
be pretty good and what is also
beautiful about what's happening here is
that all sorts of people
many of them from the tech world are
stepping up and getting into this fight
David saxo I've had on the show a couple
times was on Tucker last night we're
going to show you a clip of that in just
a moment also talking about Apple and
China and a whole bunch more uh but
before we do let me talk to you guys
about Mike box uh you know that 60 of
U.S pork production comes from one
company owned by the Chinese and their
Hogs are given something called
ractopamine which is banned in 160
countries including China yet you find
it in your grocery aisle every day well
there's a better way guys I'd like to
tell you about moink that's moo plus
oink moink delivers grass-fed and
grass-finished beef and lamb pastured
pork and chicken and sustainable wild
caught Alaskan salmon straight to your
door boink Farmers Farm like our
grandparents did and as a result moink
meat tastes like it should because the
Family Farm just does it better the
moink difference is a difference you can
taste and you can feel good knowing that
you're helping family farm stay
financially independent as well you
choose the meat delivered in every box I
like rib eyes to chicken breasts to pork
chops to salmon fillets and much more
plus you can cancel any time my personal
favorite is there filet mignon Shark
Tank host Kevin O'Leary called moink's
bacon the best bacon he's ever tasted
and ring door founder JB simenov jumped
at the chance to invest in moink plus
they guarantee you'll say oink oink I'm
just so happy I got moaned keep American
farming going by signing up at
moinkbox.com Reuben right now and
listeners of this show get a free filet
mignon in every order for a year that's
one of the best filet mignons you'll
ever taste but for a limited time that's
m-o-i-n-k-box.com
reubenwankbox.com Reuben and now back to
me okay so let's continue with sort of
the culture War the tech War the
worldwide government War right it's all
happening right in front of us guys uh
so David sacks
was on uh well first let me throw back
to something for just a sec so Elon
tweeted about a impending War what seems
like an impending war with apple now
Apple of course is the ubiquitous
company that we are all keeping in our
pocket that many of us have on our
watches that we all have their laptops
and computers they have sort of become
part of everything that that's how we
get our entertainment Apple TV they're
just sort of in and around everything
and what they also have control of is
the App Store so if you are building a
tech company and you want to get an app
on their App Store you have to play by
their rules now I don't have an inherent
problem with that they've built an
interesting Marketplace just like Amazon
built a Marketplace they have certain
rules that must be uh you have to you
know do what they say in essence you to
get your app on their store and all of
that stuff but suddenly as Elon has
taken over Twitter and remember he has
not increased hate he has not threatened
anybody or anything like that suddenly
apple is thinking about booting the
Twitter app from the App Store so Elon
tweeted this Apple has also threatened
to withhold Twitter from its App Store
but won't tell us why now what's
interesting about this guys is you
remember right after January 6th what
happened there was parlor parlor had 23
million people on it that's a ton of
people there was a there was a huge
Exodus from Twitter happening because
people were not happy with censorship
they went over to parlor and then after
January 6th Amazon in effect because
they were using Amazon servers Amazon
AWS Amazon web service services so this
is the underbelly of the internet this
is the infrastructure of the internet
that allows the websites to be up and
running Amazon just blew them apart
after January 6. did they do it because
people were coordinating the attack the
Insurrection on it parlor or did they do
it because parlor was now come
competition to Facebook Instagram
Twitter Etc the answer obviously is the
latter because it has come out we
covered it a while back that more of the
coordination for January 6 was done on
Facebook than anywhere else but for some
reason Facebook servers didn't get blown
up
anyway David sax who was one of the
founders of PayPal he's actually an
investor in locals and a friend of mine
he was on Tucker last night talking
about this issue because Apple now is
the gatekeeper of all of the things that
you can get on your phone and if a great
product exists but nobody can get to it
has it ever been created in the first
place I think that's how the phrase goes
uh here's Saxon Tucker but in the
meantime we are very happy to be joined
by David sacks he's one of the founders
of PayPal he spent the last 25 years as
a major figure in the tech world and has
been watching very carefully what's
happening with Elon Musk after the
acquisition of Twitter you know what
apple is doing in China is not that
different from what apple is doing in
the U.S they are willing to engage in
censorship on a global basis on behalf
of their true pay masters and by pay
masters I don't mean consumers Apple has
them completely locked up what I mean is
the party in power whether that's in
Beijing or Washington this is the quid
pro quo that maggot Democrats have made
of course by Mega Democrats and
referring to Microsoft Apple Google and
Amazon they have the most lucrative
monopolies in history and want to
continue minting money undisturbed and
in exchange for that they will donate
lavishly at the Democratic party and
they're willing to kneecap their
political opponents with censorship if
that's what the partying power requires
this basically happened here is that the
government has found a kind of loophole
in the First Amendment the first
amendment is stated it only applies to
government to Congress but if the
government can basically get big Tech to
do its censorship for it it can claim
that this was done by private actors the
problem is that the town square has been
privatized when content got digitized it
got centralized in the hands of a few
big tech companies and the problem here
though is that these big tech companies
aren't just acting on their own they're
acting uh you know at the behest of of
the government Washington
okay so the last line is what I want to
focus on no one is saying that a tech
company doesn't have the right to do
what it wants but at this point at this
point because we know they're telling us
they are literally telling us Jen saki
told us we flag posts Korean Jean-Pierre
were having meetings about this all the
time we know that the government is
applying pressure on private and or
public companies to limit certain
people's speech we know that the
government is telling them hey you got
to watch out for misinformation then of
course what the question is is what is
misinformation misinformation usually
turns out to be true while they are the
ones peddling
actual misinformation under the guise of
it being the truth so they've got this
whole thing backwards and at what point
at what point do the founding documents
which are the things that are protecting
us right now right the greatest man-made
documents in the history of the world to
ensure that we can speak freely it's the
jealousy of even even other people that
live in Western countries that are
largely free say Canada say Australia
the UK they don't have the protections
that we have but the government has
figured out a way around it and that's
why they're coming after Elon because as
I said earlier they know he knows
something there is simply no doubt on
that day that Donald Trump was booted
off Twitter Facebook Pinterest Instagram
give me a funny website that he must
have been booted off of PornHub
Spotify thank you
um that they coordinated something who
figure who put the plan into place right
when people were being banned and booted
when Dr Robert Malone who has more of
the patents on mRNA technology than
anyone after he goes on Joe Rogan
uh he gets booted from Twitter
how does this stuff happen did the
government have anything to do with it
when I got booted from Twitter back in
July of 2021 for saying that mandates
were coming and vaccines weren't working
was it someone was it just a social
justice Warrior who worked at Twitter
possible but was it somebody in the
intelligence services or in the
administration that was also working
with them we know from those documents
that were leaked a couple weeks ago that
The Intercept covered that the
government had access a place where they
could actually uh submit what they
wanted removed and then the tech
companies would do it
so we got a big problem here and this
problem is a worldwide problem because
now apple is not only thinking about
booting Twitter here which would which
would severely hamper our Free Speech
but they are really cracking down on
these protests in China it's rather
extraordinary uh Saxman on to talk about
that I just got to finally ask you a
personal question so you've you've been
in this business at the top of this
business you know all your life
effectively I'm sure you've seen
everything in the tech world were you
shocked to learn that Apple was
preventing
non-violent protesters in China from
communicating with each other
it is pretty shocking because the way
that it was Don Tucker was they had a an
update it was like 16.1.1 or something
like that and they didn't say normally
what they do is when they do an update
they put in the the release notes what
they're changing and they said in the
release notes they were changing you
know doing bug fixes and so on they
didn't mention that they were limiting
the use of this airdrop feature normally
Apple is very proud of their releases
and they're eager to tell consumers what
it is that they're doing but in this
case for some reason they didn't mention
it and you have to okay I know this is a
little insidery Tech stuff but this is
super interesting so we've shown you
some of the videos over the last couple
days of what's going on in China there
are massive protests against their zero
covid policy and because it's a
communist country people don't protest
that often because you know what happens
you end up in jail or you end up getting
killed but people have had enough people
are dying because they're locked in
buildings and all this stuff so what
happened was people were sharing videos
using iPhones people were sharing videos
using airdrops so that you could take a
video okay this is a little technical
but this is what was happening they
would take a video and then using
airdrop you could send it to like
everyone around you right and then they
could send it to everyone around them
and everything else so then Apple put
this update in people download the
update they don't put it in the warning
as sax described you know in the little
message when you download an update they
tell you we did this we did that we
fixed this bug we did this they didn't
put it in there and then suddenly they
hampered all of the ability of probably
millions of people in China to be able
to share what's going on on the ground
there why did Apple do that why did Tim
Cook do that
do you think they might work with
governments do you think they might want
to be in bed with the Chinese why is it
that the NBA never says anything bad
about China but will always say bad
things about America do you see how this
is all coming together but you know what
guys there are some people standing up
not only is Tucker standing up not only
is Elon Musk standing up and and David
Saxon you know the funny thing I'm not
sure if you all put it together but Elon
Musk who of course co-founded PayPal
with Peter Thiel it was also with David
sack so these guys who have been doing
stuff building real products and
industries for now it's probably 30 some
odd years they oddly seem to be maybe
not oddly they seem to be the ones that
are leading the charge to to save us and
get us out of some of this nonsense as
well which is pretty good but there are
other people doing it too and you're not
going to believe it but one of them
happens to be right here in the Free
State of Florida Ron DeSantis yesterday
went out of his way to stand by the
people of China send a message to Apple
and send a message to the Communist
Regime there's reports that apple is not
allowing the protesters to use this
airdrop function where they're trying to
communicate that obviously is providing
Aid and comfort to the CCP and so you
see that report and that's very
concerning and then when you also hear
reports that apple is threatening to
remove Twitter from the App Store
because Elon Musk is actually opening it
up for free speech and is restoring a
lot of accounts that were uh unfairly
and illegitimately suspended for putting
out accurate information about covid
that's like one of the main things
that's being reinstated so many things
these experts were wrong at and you had
people on Twitter that were calling that
out and Twitter the old regime and
Twitter their response was to try to
just suffocate the dissent and and Elon
Musk knows that's not a winning formula
and so he's providing free speech and so
if Apple responds to that uh by nuking
them from from the App Store you know I
think that that would be a huge huge
mistake and it would be a really raw
exercise of monopolistic power that I
think would Merit a response uh from the
United States Congress and so don't be a
vassal of the CCP on one hand and then
you use your corporate power in the
United States on the other to suffocate
Americans and try to suppress their
right to express themselves
clean clear honest standing up for the
right things it's not that hard it's not
that hard if you just have The Bravery
to do it again the two issues that apple
is doing right now
one this elimination of the airdrop
feature in China so that people cannot
protest against their government people
who are being starved people who are
being forced out of work and that cannot
leave their houses Apple felt oh we will
help the government do that and then
what is Apple doing here on this side of
the pond on this side of the world apple
is saying hey you know what we might
just get rid of Twitter we might just
kill that thing not because anything
bad's happening on there in reality
objectively bad but because we don't
like the idea that
our regime here I like that DeSantis
always calls them the regime the Twitter
regime the CCP regime the Biden regime
that our regime here is not happy with
people being able to stand up for
themselves and share ideas and share
information and fight actual
misinformation uh DeSantis went on to
defend the people of China something
that we all should be doing right now I
just want to make a comment about what
we've been seeing going on in China
this zero covid policy is Draconian it
violates people's Liberties and it is
completely unscientific and the people
of China are right to be able to speak
out and protest against what the Chinese
Communist party is doing this CCP has a
maniacal desire to exert total control
over its population zero covid is really
just the pretext for them to do do what
they want to do anyways and that is not
a model that can work over the long term
the people in China are finally speaking
out against it and I just think we need
these Draconian covid policies to go to
the ash heap of History where they
belong
zero covid is the pretext that's the key
line there remember these last couple
days we've shown you these videos of
fauci talking about zero covet and
talking about what's going on in China
and he's like well you know you want to
lock down and have it have an end time
to it because you want to save elderly
people I don't understand why they are
doing it and it's like yes you do yes
you do you're not just a mad scientist
which is exactly what you are Anthony
fauci you are also a communism apologist
you think that it is okay to lock people
in and it is not even if it would save
some lives it doesn't give the
government endless all-encompassing
power to do whatever it wants with the
citizens on top of the fact that you're
going to cause all sorts of other health
problems and also generally people don't
like to starve to death and a whole
bunch more I'm telling you guys Rhonda
said this I know it doesn't say it on
his desk up in Tallahassee he in effect
is the is the leader of the Free World
right now and he is in some ways he is
the president of the free United States
hopefully he will be president of the
United States but he is choosing to
fight right he was at an event there in
Florida to talk about some incredible
infrastructure projects that we're doing
here in Florida maybe we'll cover them
over the next couple days but he's doing
all sorts of stuff with roads and
housing and a whole bunch more and
rebuilding Southwest Florida and all
that he went out of his way to stand up
for Freedom it's not the easiest thing
to do he doesn't want China to be his
enemy right he doesn't want to be
fighting with apple but it's sort of
like the Disney thing which we'll get to
in a moment if they're going to do evil
[ __ ] then every now and again a good guy
is going to stand up and fight for the
right thing so he seems to be the only
leader right now in America that's
calling him out on it and the guy
deserves some freaking credit and he
deserves some some of our defense but
let's contrast Ron DeSantis with one of
the worst
um the leader yeah you know who I'm
going to well you know you're thinking
right now all right is it Trudeau or
Newsome Trudeau or Newsome we're going
to Trudeau today uh Justin Trudeau up in
Canada absolutely horrible human being I
believe he may be part lizard
um he is in the most ironic sense
possible now condemning China for the
way that they're treating their people
uh of course this is the same guy who is
locking up truckers who is closing bank
accounts who was calling them terrorists
and white supremacists and a whole bunch
more uh but uh now he's condemning China
but I think you're going to see that's
not really what he means take a look
Canadians uh are watching very closely
obviously everyone in China should be
allowed to express themselves should be
allowed to share their
um their perspectives and indeed protest
we're going to continue to ensure that
China knows we'll stand up for human
rights we'll stand with people who are
expressing themselves we also need to
make sure that China places around the
world are respecting journalists and
their ability to do their job
when I say Solas like these people are
soulless I just don't know of a better
phrase to say
than Solas when it comes to this like if
you have a human soul I think there is
some connection between the human soul
and Truth everything that he said right
there yeah I believe those things we
should be standing with the Chinese
people and we should always stand with
people against evil regimes that want to
control them and all sorts of stuff like
that but just in Trudeau you were doing
the exact same stuff to your people you
were expanding your emergency Powers you
were hunting down good people and
demanding that people not protest and
everything else so you're just you're
just soulless I don't know what else to
say you are you are not good and we see
you we see you just in Trudeau let's
flash back to nine years ago because if
you wonder about Justin Trudeau and how
does a guy do something like this how
does a guy and I get it I suppose his
hair is nice and he wears the nice socks
um and how does a guy lock his own
people up then you sort of go after
China but at the same time he's doing
the same things that China is doing it's
almost like he really likes China it's
almost like he really likes power and
that everything about him is just a
complete facade and a fraud could that
possibly be do we have video from 2013
my God even with sun TV watching for any
slip he was asked which country he most
admired and referred to China there's a
level of uh admiration I actually have
for China
um because they're you know basic
dictatorship is allowing them uh to
actually turn their economy around on a
dime and say we need to go green as fast
as we need to start you know investing
in solar I mean there is a flexibility
that I know Stephen Harper must dream
about of having a dictatorship that he
could do everything he wanted uh quite
interesting he's so gross of what he's
talking about is the conservative prime
minister at the time Stephen Harper that
Harper must want that that dictatorship
kind of stuff except he's the one that
wanted and these morons are laughing as
he's saying it
let's continue to connect all of the
pieces of this puzzle because as we talk
about Apple and giant corporations
another giant corporation that has
clamped down on people's ability to
speak freely is Disney because Disney
got all in this quote-unquote don't say
gay thing here in Florida DeSantis hit
them back and I said it you can find
videos from six months ago or whatever
it was that my feeling was that not only
was this not going to go well for Disney
and when then we saw the stock go down
they released what was the movie they
released this past week that absolutely
bombed you know what it what was it
called
Strange World absolutely bombed because
parents have had it with the woke stuff
and the whole movie was was all the woke
nonsense but I said it about six months
ago that at the time Bob chapic was the
uh was the CEO that I felt it was going
to take him down because once you've let
the woke virus in once you have the
diversity inclusion and Equity offices
in the building and everyone's focused
on how many black people are doing uh
animation for this movie and how many
gay people do we have here and have we
chopped off enough penises and all of
those things I did it again every now it
always makes me think of you I don't
know why
um
once you do that once you take your eye
off the mission and the mission at
Disney should be to make great movies it
should be to make great TV shows to have
the best theme parks possible to not
wreck Star Wars and make every Marvel
movie exactly the same but once you've
brought in these ideas of equity and
inclusion you're just damaging the
product I felt that it was going to take
out Bob Jacob JPEG and of course yes he
did resign and now they have brought
back former Disney CEO Bob Iger I guess
they got to hire a guy's name Bob and he
did his first town hall uh and basically
said we're gonna ease up on the woke
stuff because at the end of the day he's
a businessman and you're not going to
believe this guys businessmen often look
at the numbers and they go boy we did
something this way and we lost a lot of
money if we do it that way I think we're
going to get more money so
Bob Iger here's a virtual question many
cast members had wished that Disney
stayed out of politics Will Disney stay
out of making political statements
you know I think there's a Mis
perception here about what politics is
and I think that some of the subjects
that have proven to be controversial as
it relates to Disney have been branded
political and I don't necessarily
believe they are I don't think when you
were telling stories and attempting to
be a good citizen of the world that
that's political
just not how I view it do I like the
company being embroiled in controversy
of course not it can be distracting and
it can have a negative impact on the
company and to the extent that I can
work to kind of quiet things down I'm
going to do that
I mean they're going to take him out too
right the more that he lets the inmates
run the Asylum and maybe they're on
notice now like guys everyone shut up
about this stuff but they'll go after
him because they are on a I would say
cult-like mission to indoctrinate people
into their woke ideology and there's an
awful lot of them who still work at
Disney but he wants to you know he wants
to kind of quiet things down let's not
be as so perhaps overt about it but
what's the reasoning for it is it
because Disney as an organization
suddenly saw the light or is it because
Ron DeSantis fought back Ron DeSantis
took away their special tax benefits he
took away other benefits that the state
was giving Disney because they chose to
get in on this nonsensical thing and
then what happened well the citizens of
Florida kind of dug it because the guy
wanted a freaking ridiculous Landslide
by 20 points Iger continued to go on
they talked a little bit more about
don't say gay which I don't like calling
that it's HP 1557 and what they're going
to do related to that all right another
virtual question what is your stance on
the don't say gay situation this company
has been telling stories for 100 years
and those stories have had a meaningful
positive impact on the world and one of
the reasons they've had a meaningful
positive impact is because one of the
core values of our storytelling is
inclusion and acceptance and tolerance
we also when you tell stories it's a
delicate balance you're talking to an
audience but it's also important to
listen to an audience it's important to
have respect for the people that you're
serving that you're trying to reach and
not have disdain for it it's so
interesting because it's hard to have
sympathy for like a giant corporate
Overlord uh to some extent but another
way it's like man he's trying to have it
both ways because he's saying on one
hand we're going to have inclusion and
all of that stuff that's code to the
woksters you guys will be good to go but
then what he's saying there at the end
is we got to make some money we got to
make a good product that people are
going to come to and see and share and
all of those things and I think those
things are in direct conflict so I think
this battle is uh is gonna get is gonna
continue between Disney and Florida I
think there's going to be a continued
internal battle with Disney and uh and
sorry what what was the movie
strange world
did you see Strange World you didn't see
Strange World okay
um you're not working hard enough if you
saw a strange World
um I think that they're going to realize
these products do not work but then will
the people who are making the products
that work at Disney want to continue
working there we shall see uh Governor
DeSantis responded to uh iger's comments
I was sorry to see us
dragged into that battle
um and I have no idea exactly what its
ramifications are in terms of the
business itself what I can say is the
state of Florida has been important to
us for a long time and we have been very
important to the State of Florida that
is something I'm extremely mindful of
and will articulate if I get the chance
how do you respond to that he's talking
about you
we didn't drag them in Tucker they went
in on their own and not only opposed the
bill they threatened to get it repealed
these are parents rights important
policies in our state that are very
popular and so they brought this on
themselves all we did was stand up for
what's right and yes they're a big
powerful company but you know what we
stand up for our folks
yeah yeah the scientists didn't choose
this thing they basically Disney
basically said we're gonna get rid of
DeSantis because of this don't say gay
bill that doesn't even have the word gay
in it but you know me I've got a
backbone like a ramrod
and I even said the word gay to DeSantis
back in June all right so first off we
have to start with the obvious one
gay
[Laughter]
[Applause]
he didn't even flinch
so why did the Santa's fight why did he
choose the fight which again the people
of Florida
clearly like without question have said
you were on the right side of this fight
why did he do it because he was voted in
to protect Floridians and the rights of
the people that live here he was not
voted in to defend Disney or
corporations or globalist Empires or
anything else he also told me a bit
about that but I think Disney took it
one step further when they put out this
incredible statement after they already
did all their virtue signaling after we
signed the bill saying this was somehow
a violation of Human Rights and that
they would work to see that parents
rights and education were repealed
through the legislature and I'm just
thinking to myself
um you know I took a note to support the
laws and Constitution of the U.S and the
State of Florida I did not take an oath
to subcontract out my leadership to a
corporation based in Burbank California
they don't run the this state
guys this is how we win the culture war
and ultimately win the political war and
ultimately win the war on freedom look I
know that the the Red Wave did not
happen the way some of us would have
liked that's political racehorse stuff
and it's hard to figure out sometimes
why people vote the way they vote but
the culture War which then leads to why
people vote a certain way right it's a
generational thing uh if you can start
winning on that and there are wins right
DeSantis beat Disney Then crushed in the
election here Elon beat Twitter and that
Twitter tried to stop him from buying it
now he's got it and he's fighting the
freaking machine and Republicans now for
the first time in a long time are
standing alongside of him right what's
that Kevin McCarthy video that I showed
you all about we are standing beside
this guy sometimes if you do the right
thing like DeSantis if you do the right
thing like Elon you start making other
people a little braver to do the right
thing as well that's the ripple effect
and it and it takes time and I think
that means that right now we have a
certain moment that that could be really
Transcendent let's continue with these
Transcendent moments uh Don Lemon who uh
was a well who he purports to be a
journalist but then also says he's not
political you know he's not political
but he's also not a journalist I mean
he's just a guy who gives his opinion
poorly guys as a journalist he got
booted from the late night slot at CNN
and when you get booted on CNN they
don't fire you out right they either put
you on MSN they throw you to another
Network like MSNBC or they give you the
morning spot so they threw him to the
morning anyway he was on Stephen
Colbert's late night show and Stephen
Colbert who you know the the budget on
that show is bananas he's got like 20
writers massive staff it used to be the
number one show in late night when
Letterman had it uh now it is not that's
Greg Gutfeld in his band of like three
people that he's got uh anyway lemon was
on Colbert and listen to what he says
about CNN and try not to fall out of
your seat and if you're drinking
something uh watch out for the spit take
the word street is that you guys aren't
allowed to be liberal anymore is that is
that the case I don't think we ever were
liberal what yes I don't think we ever
worked not me saying that that's the
people out there saying that he's not
letting you be liberal anymore well I
listen I think that I think what Chris
is
saying is that he wants Republicans
sensible Republicans he wants us to hold
people to account but he wants people to
come on and feel comfortable with coming
on and talking on on CNN and appearing
on CNN so if you invite someone in your
house you want to make them comfortable
but also but by the nature of what we do
we have to hold people to account and so
that doesn't necessarily mean that we're
going liberal or conservative or
whatever it just means that we are doing
what we do and that's good journalism
he's such a shell of nothing with thick
room glasses like it's just nothing what
he's saying there he's showing you
exactly what the factory settings of all
of this stuff is the factory settings is
basically we are Democrats so when he's
framing that conversation he's saying
well you know uh it's not that we
weren't liberal what does he say uh in
essence at the same time we have to show
Republicans that were nice well if you
weren't liberal then Republicans
wouldn't feel that way notice the
conversation never goes in the back he
doesn't go well we weren't conservative
so uh you know we have to be respectful
of Democrats like the the basic default
position that these people have is wrong
so that every conclusion that comes
after that is always wrong and of course
Colbert just getting up there and he's
just he's just nothing he's he's
absolutely nothing except what the
machine wants that's exactly what
Colbert is which is precisely what I
told Bill Maher a couple weeks ago he's
Colbert
yeah like those guys to me they're just
the worst sort of partisan nonsense you
want everybody part of that is we don't
hide it like he doesn't like me and I
don't like him and we don't deny it and
we don't like it no but he's nothing
yeah he's nothing he's very successful
no no but he's just giving the machine
what it wants all the time you giving
you for my differences with that I
totally respect you he's well said yeah
giving the machine What It Wants I wish
I had thought of that phraseology that
so giving the machine what it wants
which is also what lemon is doing it's
what the people at MSNBC are doing it's
what it's what big Tech has done just
can we constantly keep everyone enraged
confused thinking Republicans are racist
can we lie about all of the issues
whether it is covid or very fine people
on both sides or the Jesse small out
hooks I do this all the time or Brett
Kavanaugh or Kyle Rittenhouse all of the
lies that they push because it oh you
know the police are racist and systemic
racism and boys or girl all of the stuff
guys you get it and and if you keep
giving the machine What It Wants You
Will you will get jobs I guess you will
be successful in media and everything
else it's a little harder I suppose to
to be honest and fight for truth and
reason and human rights I suppose it's a
little harder to do those things but I
think it's well worth it and I think
that there's a couple people stepping up
right now who I've repeatedly mentioned
on this show uh so how do you know that
per that it's shifting how do you know
it's shifting because now
the lefties the MSNBC people the
Democrats The Joy reads of the world
they are now talking about the culture
War because they're feeling like they're
starting to lose it it's not cool to be
on the side of censorship why is no good
music come out of the left or or just
like the mainstream machine in a long
time
why is that because you can't make good
music if you're constantly looking over
your shoulder going oh I might offend
this person with that word or I didn't
use this gender pronoun with that person
or whatever it might be so watch out
it's only one MSNBC clip today uh here
is Joy read and MSNBC contributor uh
mccaskill's former Senator mccaskill uh
having a manic really just like losing
their [ __ ] over the culture wars because
they know that they're kind of losing
them so it is really fair I think to say
that the culture wars have become the
main attraction in the Republican party
not policy not how big should the
government be or what tax policy should
be or even what foreign policy should be
but rather culture wars and I don't
think most Americans think that's what
this should all be about and I think in
the long run they're going to pay a
price for it joy and in the end if
you're making it illegal to teach about
the Holocaust without telling the other
side or the other side died of slavery
don't sit there and get mad at Trump for
for eating with the Nazi because maybe
you ought to look at your own policies
and talk to the man and the woman in the
mirror that's all
again this woman Joy Reed it's like who
at Ms MSNBC which is of course owned by
NBC which is a giant Corporation I think
owned by GE it's like who hired this
woman this crazy person no one is saying
you have to teach both sides of the
Holocaust you might want to teach why
people in Germany would start supporting
Nazis that would be interesting and I do
think we kind of teach that right nobody
is saying that absolutely nobody is
saying that and this idea of the it's
interesting that they're talking about
the culture wars now because they're
starting to lose it and I also think
Claire mccaskill is wrong she's going oh
we're not talking about the size of
government we're talking about the
culture wars well the culture wars are
directly related to the size of
government because if you don't want a
teacher to have the power to talk about
gender with your kid that means you want
smaller government she's saying well we
don't want we're not talking about
taxation well in the free states in the
red States we have lower taxes because
we don't want to give all of that money
to the government to have these endless
programs to then push through education
all the race nonsense of the gender
nonsense and everything else so there is
some good stuff happening people I'm
telling you there really is some good
stuff happening it doesn't all translate
to votes overnight
um
but I think if you stay aware of it you
can you can kind of see it and then you
can you can help the people who are out
there trying to fight for it whether
it's Elon Musk or Ron DeSantis or
whoever you can just by just being out
there and and sharing videos and things
like you can play a little role in in
getting some of this stuff back I really
do believe it we got a cold close for
you in just a minute or two but real
quick uh some comments from
reubenreport.locals.com and by the way
as long as I've talked about uh big Tech
so much uh you know again you don't have
to we enjoy it when people join locals
it's five dollars a month to join or you
can get the year for I think 50 bucks
and then you can directly interact with
me and you get extra content and add
free stuff and all that but if you just
want to stay in touch with me just get
you can join locals for absolutely free
and then you'll get push notifications
from me so that if I get booted off
Twitter or I get booted off YouTube or
anything else you will still be able to
directly contact me that is between me
and you guys the audience big Tech
cannot stop us from doing that even if
they blew local off the store if you've
got it on your phone you're good to go
anywho alley cat says I don't know if I
can bear to watch the clips of the crazy
ass women on The View anymore I know I
know
maybe we're gonna have to have a lunch
meeting and discuss how many Clips per
week and we do we showed three different
view Clips today if I'm not mistaken
it's a lot four it was four Jesus
but it's like it's important to show
because these people are out there and
and people are paying attention to them
and we must help these people
California runaway I like that name says
I love how she demands Elon use his
money the way she wants what about all
your money Alyssa that's right that
who's the boss money she's got the Tony
Danza money that you know it's like lady
you've got millions I have no doubt you
have millions you know some billionaires
how about you fix this stuff that line
where she's like you know what he could
just solve uh world hunger just like
that and it's like I know some
billionaires they're good well ask them
lady
Geller says China isn't going green
they're building new coal plants yeah I
wanted to mention that actually so in
that Trudeau clip from 2013 he's like I
I admire them because they're going
green and they're doing all this stuff
and it's like no they haven't done any
of that they're still going through
their Industrial Revolution they're
still building coal plants uh India is
still going through its Industrial
Revolution the idea that if we just
re-jigger our economy and give AOC all
the power in the world that somehow the
air is going to be cleaner and the
temperatures will not change it's you I
gotta bridge to sell you I gotta bridge
to sell you uh guys as I said
reubenreport.locals.com if you want to
play along during the show and we leave
you
this was a good one we could have opened
with this one uh Biden had a speech
yesterday where he just fumbled so many
things and and here's a real special one
see you tomorrow as I told you if I had
you running in front of me when I was
playing flankerback I could have been an
All-American man
could have been big it could have been
big